so Johan great to have you in the studio
thank you you've been doing very
successful in property I have you've
Paterson sold how many deals now
probably about getting close to about
eight or so ideals and great in what
time period probably lost two months
yeah fantastic so I just thought I mean
hey I have to have me on the show
everyone's talking about you you've been
doing business as well with a lot of my
Academy members yeah you sell for now
and accounting member it we'll get to
that why don't we start this from the
beginning tell me about your story and
what got you into property cool well the
whole background is actually quite a
lengthy story but many years ago while
we ago so you know we've been in
investors for a long time you know if
traditional investors stocks and shares
commodities such as silver and gold and
then property was always one of our
biggest things but we always thought we
needed a massive amount of money to get
a mess into property yeah quite a few
friends of mine who are quite wealthy a
few business owners and and one was
actually my employer for a long time as
well and we've always spoken about
getting involved in property getting
involved in property and I think we'd
meet about for over the last three years
about every few months and just
formulating how we're going to get
involved but they never really pulled
the trigger so I was like well I think I
finally need to if this is going to
happen I need to make it happen yeah and
then I came across your stuff by chance
and then started listening and then I
was thinking well it makes sense then I
got we went down to the crash course had
some fun there and then but we went to
the crash course knowing we're gonna
sign up for further training and that's
when I think you spoke about the DfE we
went to the DfE but I think it was on my
heart the whole time to go on Academy
yeah I heard great things about the
Academy is you know speak to people
about the Academy and I thought himself
now that's where I need to be so two
days into the DfE we were just like yeah
you know it's pulled the trigger with
this go there but it was quite a
interesting one because we we work full
time but at the DfE I decided okay the
property is what I want to do and I
think that was the last time I went to
work who's just before the DfE
after the DfE I remember asking asking
my wife and like listen yeah is it okay
if I take a month off it was originally
a week but then it's like okay then at
the DfE I'm like now I need a little bit
more time I'm gonna take a month off and
then we were going to invest and then
spend and and build my deal sourcing
business yeah and then obviously just go
from there but then you know a month
went into two months and in two months
and three months and not selling any
deals viewing loads of properties
viewing a lot of things but you know
it's just not wasn't really happening
and so but we just kept on pushing kept
on pushing get on viewings there was a
lot of frustrations a lot of things fell
through a lot of deals that we had you
know whole Patchett we're looking into
something happen in the whole patch fell
through just shut itself for various
reasons it wasn't Gotham City no no it
might as well pretty close to Gotham
City might as well be called Gotham but
then at the end so that happened and you
know we were getting really frustrated
and at the end of the day you know
because I'm not working anymore she's my
wife still working full-time so we kept
manage to keep up with bills but then
about a couple of months ago you know
the money started running out and they
were still no deals on the table and I
just remember we had a business meeting
one evening where she was like okay so
what are we gonna do now and I thought
to myself well I'm not going back to
work I refused to because I felt like
going back to work would be taking a
step backwards and that's not really
what we wanted so but I did tell her on
that day this year we are on the cusp I
can feel it we just you know just one
small push and were there and prior to
that I've met James on from a few times
and we've spoken to him I remember
doesn't know James Armstrong was on
Windows Wednesday yes and and it's on
the Academy yes I'm quite funny enough
it was James
Armstrong's when is on a Wednesday that
inspired me to go down the dual sourcing
room right so I don't even think he
knows that so it was so you know every
opportunity I had to
to meet with him to pick his brain I
took it yeah and but then also you know
I met with him one time and my dude I
remember we were I was sitting across
from him from the table I'm like how do
I get from this side of the table to
your side of the table because obviously
as you know James Thomson was extremely
successful really good at what he does
arguably one of the best deal sources
out there and you know that's the person
I wanted to learn from this person whose
brain I wanted to pick the most yeah and
he I confirm that James is fantastic and
then you explain to me a few things and
then at the end of it is like well he
offers some mentoring as well yeah so
I'm like okay but then I'm thinking
myself well I'm not selling any deals so
I can't really sign up to his mentoring
let me sell a couple of deals and I'll
be able to do that but then you know we
sat down for this business meeting with
my wife and then all of a sudden I'm
like well I'm not going back to work so
I think you know and even if I did go
back to work with all the you know the
loans we took out to pay for Academy and
everything else it would we'd still be
in a very we wouldn't really be going
forward we would be going backwards so
he said well one final nudge or one
final push we decided then okay fine
let's just take out one final loan sign
up for James's mentoring yeah because I
felt it was there because I was so close
everything was just lining up with just
a few tweaks that I needed and then
literally two weeks after that the first
deals just sold and sold and sold and
sold and I've sold deals consistently
now one or two deals are we consistently
every week since then so it's just
really it's being it's just time to
cross Kade now and just grow and
everything so no it's so how much how
much now have you made or how much of
you like you know sort of deal sourcing
business how many it's about ten
thousand a month yeah homeand ten
thousand a month yeah and what was your
previous job I'm a joiner by trade
yeah so I've been in the construction
industry twelve years now and what was
the typical
it's more typical average salary when
you were joiner well my salary was
higher than your average joiner because
of the reputation that I built okay for
myself in the industry I remember a few
months ago I got a call from the office
saying accountants have been in touch
with us and we're paying you more than
we are actually making on you so we're
losing money on you so so they obviously
negotiated price again but that's pretty
much what I realized that I can't go any
further than this
yeah I've hit the ceiling in my OD'ing
capacity because if they paying me well
at the end of it they ended up paying me
exactly what they were getting for me so
they weren't making any money off me so
I was making about before tax probably a
thousand a week okay so you know a four
thousand four thousand a month before
tax and then you quit that yes to do
property yes and then you realized that
actually you weren't making any money
from property now so you go to a port
you thinking oh my goodness I'm gonna go
back to that but so in this stage of
this difficult desert experience for you
when you've quit work you've got loans
out to go on the Academy yeah you are
doing lots of viewings but not making
any money at that point you're gonna get
one or two ways you're either gonna
become really successful and it's going
to be a great part of the story or
you're gonna quit and then you're just
going to be down as a as a failure rate
to my to my store of course you'll be
one of the one of those who didn't make
it so what was the difference between
those people because everyone has the
situation at some point normally where I
mean not normally people join the
Academy within three days or suddenly
you know financially free it's a it's a
journey their process I should say it's
a process that takes time what do you
think the difference is between those
that go on and become successful and
those that don't knows to quit I think
well I'm a firm believer in
introspection so I'm always a lot of
times about once a month I would just
take time to myself and just analyze the
previous month my actions how I went
about things and then to see how I can
improve on all the things that I'm doing
and I would I remember sitting down
before even any of this happened and I
remember when I first in when you first
did the DfE when I first quit my job and
that you know I've coined the word
I call it procrastination so you know
you're taking just enough action to make
yourself feel good about yourself but
you're not really getting anywhere and I
think a lot of people and I think
especially for me I needed to realize I
was in that place because it's easy to
take some action and it's not working
it's not for me
so you know this it just doesn't work
but I think as soon as I realized that I
was like no I need to take specific
action I need to double my or even
triple or you know strong cardones is
10x your everything and because you know
I've been a student of life pretty much
my whole life so you know I've always
been reading books consistently but my
or because of the mileage I used to do I
used to listen to audiobooks all the
time massive plethora of books in my
library and I think that's also really
helped and I think beginning before that
you know I was very leadership focused
all the books I was reading was on
leadership and leadership development
and things like that so then switch that
into business where it became you know
Robert Kiyosaki and Grant Cardone and
Napoleon Hill and and all those guys and
I think it just it is a mindset shift so
at the end of the day I think everyone
struggles with a point and they I think
everyone gets to that point we're like
ok it's sink or swim and you know the
people that they decide to swim are the
ones that just you know they just take
one more step you know they just push
you through one more time you know they
just overcome one more obstacle they
just really just beat the odds one more
time and I think if you're you know if
you get beaten down life will beat you
down but you need to stand up it's not
about how many times you fall it's about
how many times you stand up
lilian afterwards and eventually yes you
will get there you will get through and
you know you will be successful but if
you give up you won't be successful you
know that that's guaranteed at the end
of the day or we all you have to lose is
at the end of the day you are the choose
to make it work or not make it work yeah
and there are many reasons why people
fail in business like before property I
think I worth I had four words for
different business ventures leading up
to that and they all pretty much failed
for various reasons but I think when I
came into property I was like this is
gonna work
most businesses fail yeah I think the
stats are 80% in the first five years
fail yeah but there's 20% that don't
fail just because they don't go bust
sometimes they're not making any mone
like you said your your business owner
was getting you out to do stuff wasn't
making any money yeah sometimes the
business owner it makes less money than
the staff yeah and that would be counted
as a success because it didn't go bust
yeah exactly and I think it's 90 percent
fail in the first ten years that's like
the stats are staggeringly dooms
yeah and and that's why on the Academy
the stats are actually very high you go
around a little cavity event you'll
generally you'll speak to people it's
they're brand new they're making money
in property yeah that's generally the
case and I think that isn't just what
you said about used to read a lot of
books on leadership and then you switch
to overstock reading a lot of books
about money yeah what are the
differences in money principles between
the rich and the poor I think it's it's
the way you look at money I think one of
the things that really stood out to me a
lot I think it was I saw Robert Kiyosaki
who said it will grant cardone but like
you know if you don't have money that's
all you think about when you have a lot
of money you don't really care about it
because you just see it as a tool a lot
of people you don't have money
everyone's focused on money but when you
when you step into a level above that
way everyone's got money it's more about
relationship it's more about trust it's
more about you know your track record
you can have all the money in the world
but if you're not trust
no one's gonna do business with you so I
think money should be seen for what it
is is a tool and it should be used
accordingly and I think if you've got a
oh just a whack sense of a misconception
of what money is it could you could just
consume your your thought pattern and I
think for a lot of people especially
that don't have money I think it does
consume them the fact that they don't
have money because poor people think
about money whereas rich people think
about opportunities and and what they
and what they money can do so I think
that's pretty much much the difference
make sense you definitely does something
you grew up around here no no I was born
and raised in South Africa yeah and then
when I was 16 I moved to South America
in place but Paraguay for three and a
half years and then when I was 19 I
moved over to the UK so about 1213 years
ago and what brought you to the UK work
really well my dad was of the persuasion
as soon as you finish school you out the
house so he's like well I've clothed you
I fed you yeah you've gone to school
I've done I've held up my end of the
bargain
now it's time for you to go and make
something of yourself yeah he's like
there's no I'm literally I finished
school and a month later I pretty much
got kicked out the house there's a go
single so and we when my dad was growing
up there to go to the army and of cause
of the war that was going on in Angola
and things like that so that they were
patrolling the borders and he said it's
really the army turned boys into men and
one thing that I found when I moved over
to the UK it's probably not the army but
you know it's singles from here and I've
met a lot of people who came over the
same situation I did but you know they
just couldn't hack it or they couldn't
make it and I think a lot of that came
down to the way they were brought up I
think probably 80% of the people who
went home to South Africa couldn't make
it in the UK was because they you know
were brought up in a privileged
lifestyle they parrot a lot of money
they never really worked a day in their
life and now they've all of sudden got
to come to the UK and work for a living
and you know just try and and basically
yeah I got to work for a living but they
just don't know how because they don't
have the work ethic yeah so yeah that's
that's really interesting when I saw
that and before when you know and
growing up and we'd have all do all the
chores the gardening you know all of
that I was thinking to myself yeah the
season I did not enjoy it to be honest
but that gave me the work ethic I needed
when I came to the UK to be the best at
what I did and into pursue to be the
best in every endeavor that I undertook
and I think it really and then I caught
my dad one day I said thanks I really
appreciate the way that you that you
brought me up yeah and yeah
and you tell you did quite as a joiner
you're making good money good money as a
deal civilization you realized in
property you could make better money
much better money talk to me about what
you learned about deal sourcing from the
Academy from James and we met on the
Academy how did you how did you sell
that first deal Wow
the first deal obviously within deal
sourcing you've got a variety of
strategies as well you know so deal so
see itself as a strategy but then you've
got rain terrains you've got HMOs you've
got single LEDs B are ours you got two
Oh BRR HMOs and commercial so I think in
the beginning I was just trying to chase
the first one whatever it may be
I was very unorganized in what I was
doing my approach was an organized I was
looking at everything and but it was
good because you know I got to
understand what a good deal looked like
and I got to understand what but the
investors requirements are as well so in
that aspect I think deal sourcing is
great because you learn about every
single strategy and the Australia is now
that I don't really entertain personally
like I don't really focus on the rent
arrange side of things of sourcing rain
terrain deals because I would rather
spend my time sourcing brr for investors
where they can put all their money out
I think as a deal sorcerer you also need
to be aware it's not only you know the
deal the money that you're making from
the deals that you're selling but it's
also the relationship with the investor
that you're trying to both and if you
can keep your investors money working
because for example if you have an
investor that's got 50 grand and you you
know they're buying and just a standard
four or five-bedroom HTML from you as
soon as they purchase that deal you know
you've lost that investor because all
the money is tied up into that one
property but if you can get a decent brr
where they can pull out all if not most
of their money as soon as they come to
refinance they're ready to go again yeah
so from a deal sourcing standpoint you
know you're putting your investor first
because you're making very money work as
hard for it as they've worked for it
yeah and I think that's pretty clean
that's my favorite strategy yeah we are
our HMO strategy because you over that
course of time you can then you create C
or you're building quite good
relationship with your investors or a
fantastic relationship with your
investors B and they know that you have
their best interests at heart as well
yeah and a liquid investor is investor
for life as soon as they've run out of
money because everyone's got a limited
pot of cash mmm
no one can buy every single deal that
comes up but if you can if I if you can
sell them a deal where they put all
their money out and then as soon as it's
out you have the next year waiting for
them they just go straight back into it
so they're just recycling the money and
growing their portfolios at the same
time that's really nice what was the
area that you found didn't work the area
will probably work is just that it
didn't work for you yeah your strategy
basically I spend a lot of time in
Blackpool yeah a lot of time the reason
why it fell through at the end is the
isomer manager that I lined up you know
we walk around with him he viewed a few
properties with us everything was great
and then all of a sudden you just fell
off the face of earth you know we could
not get hold of this guy form you know
and we had quite a few deals lined up
one of the
the guys I knew we were ready to to JV
on a property but then the sky just
disappeared so you found some good deals
on paper yeah and you couldn't put the
Power Team together exactly and you
figured that if you're selling a deal to
an investor as a package deal you need
you need the full work you do you do
otherwise the investors gonna have a
good system in place these aren't gonna
work for them they don't want to come
back to you of course
and then that will tarnish my
relationship the thing about deal
sourcing is and I think that's why I
like it as well
it's very reputation based yeah and
because I've always had a good
reputation everything I've done I think
I was naturally drawn to deal sourcing
because you know I've always said a good
reputation is hard to get and easy to
lose and a bad reputation is easy to get
and hard to lose so you know if I'm
going to start a deal to an investor I
need to make damn sure it's a good deal
and I need to make sure that they you
know the power teams in place and you
have to make sure that you know that I
would happily buy this deal myself who's
your first investor
my first investors actually a guy I met
on the academy yeah
great guy yeah we met at one of the
events I think the deal selling mastery
yeah a master class yeah that was
amazing it's really just because I've
done the DfE and I you know I've done
the Radian revolution and infinite
returns and things like that so we did
the deal selling mastery and no I met
the guy they've you know during the you
know during the deal Sally Marcia we
always have these these tasks that we
need to go do go in estate agents and go
do this and you do that yeah so I was
actually paid up with him you know we
found each other and it happens it just
happens a guy South African as well so
we got off to a very good start and so
but we got talking and he's like yeah he
likes rain to rent but I think his main
strategy was buy refurbish refinance so
I'm like okay dude if I find something
I'll let you know and a month later we
had do you do the if would close on him
no if I find some it would yeah yeah so
if I find something
do you - any three to you he's like yo
sure go for it
so I go enough I find something and but
then no wait before that after I think
about a month after two weeks after the
deal selling mastery Alastair and them
do like a conference like a call with ya
to go on and he was on the call and
while we were on the call with texting
each other on whatsapp seeing I
everyone's doing and that's an touching
base again and you him saying again are
you still looking for BR our deals and
everything I'm like dude if I find one
I'll send it through to you so then I
found this deal I thought to myself man
this is a cracking deal and so but what
I didn't do is I did it I didn't send it
straight to him I put on my mailing list
but I texted him in the morning say dude
there's a deal coming out this afternoon
I want you to have a look at it you have
first refusal on it so if you want to
just let me know so I sent the deal out
and a few minutes later he's like I'll
take it yes please
how much did he pay six thousand six
thousand
yeah so that paid for the course at
least yeah perfectly yes oh and that's
the thing people sometimes said that my
training courses are expensive and it's
like well when I'm putting you in a room
with people that are gonna pay you six
grand I'm teaching you how to it's all
relative it is all relative yeah and I
remember I think it was James as winners
on a Wednesday when you asked him about
you know I think it made quite a bit of
money up until that point and you're
like it doesn't really matter how much
the training costs you know knowing what
I know and being where I am I'd happily
paid twice as much for the training
three times as much because it's not
just the training that you get it's the
education it's the experience it's the
collaboration with people around you
yeah it's like-minded people I think
that's the one of the greatest things is
having like minor people around you
cheering you on and you know encouraging
you to to go and be more and achieve
more and do more and I think that is
worth
more than any amount of money that you
can charge for a training course what do
you make of the people that say you
don't need to pay for the training you
can just get it all online for free I
understand where they're coming from to
a certain degree I believe there have
been people on Windows on a Wednesday
that have just watched your videos it
became financially free it's happened
twice
yeah all honesty I'm not the type of
person I need I need the support I need
the training I'm very for lack of a
better word and I need to know how
things work yeah and I think to a
certain degree that's probably my
downfall because I would probably spend
more time on figuring out how this works
and actually doing it but I think you
know training is so important it doesn't
it's like if you want to be a doctor
like I'm not gonna if you decide today
listen yeah I want to be a surgeon and
you walk into st. james's or the LGI and
you're like cannot operate on this
person like no what training have you
had yeah you know in order people can do
it without training but it's gonna take
him a lot longer they're gonna make a
lot more mistakes
they might burn a few bridges and you
know they finding everything out the
hard way the great thing about training
is and especially your training is like
you know you've done you've been there
you've done that you know you've and
it's about learning from people who are
further along than you who have made the
mistakes who have streamlined these
systems and they know exactly how the
business works and that you know that's
more than that's worth more than
anything yeah so no it's it's really
just learning from people's mistakes is
much better than making every mistake
yourself yeah totally and I think as
well the father
when you're an environment where you're
actually doing it you're picking up the
phone you were its what the difference
between reading a theory book and
actually learning to drive with an
instructor that's a lot yeah yeah
exactly
but then as soon as you learn to drive
when you know my grandmother says said
one thing to me once and I've remembered
it ever since you know you don't learn
to drive well you learn to drive after
you partial license yeah and that's and
you know
the Academy in that unit will be getting
your license but you know often can we
need to go out you need to mean to drive
yeah I need to make it happen
and I remembered that and when I got my
license I remember that and it was such
a surreal feeling driving because it
felt so strange I was literally feeling
I was driving for the furniture drive
for the first time yeah and I think the
Academy is pretty much the same you know
it's and the guys they are pretty much
our driving instructors they making sure
you're doing the right things but then
at the end of it you need to go out and
you need to drive yeah and you need to
take action and you need to make it work
and I think that is where theory and
practice becomes well when you combine
theory and practice you get results yeah
nothing's very much the most important
thing what would you say the hardest
point has been the bit where you wanted
to quit them job Wow
prove that you know the whole
blackballed scenario was really is like
but then again you know I remember we
had this business meeting with my wife
and I told her this is gonna make an
awesome story we need to just take the
last take one more step but I will never
forget that day because you know I know
you know she's always been my my biggest
support she's always been she's always
cheered me on in everything that I've
done if it's failed or if it hasn't
failed she's been my biggest cheerleader
and I remember when you know we're
sitting there and I'm I decided I was
going to go for this this mentoring with
James but you know I haven't told her
yet so we were sitting there like we
need to do this but she's like we don't
have any money I'm like I know but if we
give up now we're still not gonna have
any money so and but then the funny
thing is if we did go and take out that
loan even if I went back to work after
that
I don't even think my salary would have
been enough to cover it so it just kind
of like I'm putting myself into a
position where listening it's sink or
swim and and I know I'm gonna swim I
just needed that little extra and yeah
as soon as it as soon as I sat down with
James we were and they just started
rolling in
and things just arted happening and and
I believe I'm a very big believer in
momentum I know what momentum looks like
an hour to cultivate it on now to grow
it and you know now I just see momentum
and my whole thing now is maintaining
momentum or building momentum that's why
I have to sell for me momentum now is
one deal of week minimum and that is
momentum yeah so that's what I'm that's
what I'm growing that's what I'm pushing
for I've got a deal going out today it's
another six thousand pound deal and so
yeah it's just continuously building
momentum and pushing and pushing say
happy to afford
oh sorry how can he justify charging six
grand for one deal what would you say I
would say so basically if I came up to
you Samuel
and I said Samuel I can give you a
thousand pounds a month profit yeah
oh all he's going to cost you is six
grand and I'll give you a thousand
pounds a month for the rest of your life
sounds like a pretty good deal yeah so
that's kind of so that you know this
deal that I'm sending out today is
pretty much that six thousand pound for
the deal then to purchase the property
do it up refinance put all their money
out and then they are getting a thousand
pounds of month profit after that so I
think it's all relative once again and a
standard whereas you know and in all
honesty I see 6,000 as cheap for deals
such as this because you can buy a
standard HMO for five bit HMO 3,000
pounds yeah but you're all your money is
locked in that deal yes whereas you buy
a true BR our HMO where you pull all
your money out for six grand am i seeing
myself should be charging double that
yeah because it's still a really good
deal to the investor yeah because it's
hundred percent
well it's infinite return on investment
yeah do you talk to me a bit about the
actual finding of the deals because with
you've spoke about deals a masterclass
about how you learn to package the deal
sell it how did you get good at finding
videos I think you get good at finding
deals by finding a lot of bad deals you
need to get out there you need to just
view as many properties as boss
and in the beginning probably 95% of the
deals won't stack because you don't
really know what you're looking for
you've got good guidelines from the
Academy and from for more the training
you go and you've got very good
guidelines but unless you're actually
out there unless you're actually viewing
the deals and this you actually stacking
them yourself you never really know yeah
but so I think through the three months
of finding horrible deals I've been able
to refine what I'm looking for and now
pretty much you know I go on Rightmove I
go into an area you know I do my due
diligence on the area I see what
properties are available Mike that's a
deal that's a deal that's a deal that's
a deal and when I when I'm going out
it's pretty much just confirming what I
saw online so yeah what did you I know
what one of the training programs on the
academy is called infinite returns yes
talk to me about what you learned on
that and what happened
I think infinite returns I did that last
year it was just really interesting and
I think Anthony did a fantastic job
because as we all know Anthony's the brr
King so I learned a lot from him also on
Windows where he exactly exactly
it's great for me because when you're
talking about these guys like James and
Anthony who when they met me knew
nothing and now they're actually not
only are they wild successful but
they're now helping other people and he
was one of the trainers on infinite he
was and it's just really especially when
he started talking about infinite
returns in the beginning I was talking
to myself
you know I think I'll just stick to
normal standard HMO is they easier to
find things okay but then as soon as you
start well soon as I listen to him I'm
like yeah this is this is action there's
actually something there
this is actually and because especially
from a deal sourcing side a point you
have to put your investor first it
doesn't help you know you're charging
thousands for a deal but you know you
you've got yourself in mind because at
the end of the day it's this very
self-serving and you might grow and
invest in less but it doesn't mean some
people can invest with you as soon as
you do a deal with them and they see
that while you're you're more in it for
yourself than for them
I think it's when they decide well why
all the deal sources out there why
should I do business with you but if you
put your investor first and that's why I
love the BRR model if you put your
investor first and you show them missing
you I've got a deal for you great deal
you pull all if not most of your money
out and it's generating a positive cash
flow of about a thousand a month as soon
as you're as soon as you've refinanced
you know you're ready to go again the
next deal will be waiting for you and I
think that I think that that that's
worth more than any fee I can charge
yeah because you know you need to put
you and mr. Fitz and the BRR strategy
you mean just for any one of those
thinking what on earth you want about
buy a house push the value up you have
refurbishing it but every time you spend
a pound you might be adding three pounds
it's that two pounds against very to the
proper take and then the new value you
then get a new finance refinance pull
all your initial money out and you're
left with a property no money down
exactly that's a strategy that we go
into quite heavily yeah some of our
training talk to me about do you ever
fear that you will run out of investors
or run out of deals and then because the
income that you're making is not passive
no it's not passive do you ever fear
that you might end up running running
dry and then you end up having to get a
job again no I don't once again why
don't you have these skills once you
know what you're looking for and once
you've got the expert once you know what
you're looking for and you know how to
find it I see them everywhere now I
think my problem now is lack of
investors because I'm finding all these
deals I'm like okay now I need to sell
them to people that's why I saw some
deals to mine basis but those that don't
sell I co source through James Armstrong
and then he sells them on so you know
the deals always sell there are always
deals to sell but you know I think
growing your investor list and finding
deals are two things you really need to
do at the same time other and to be able
to maximize what you do but now I don't
think there'll be a shortage of deals
especially not the type of deals that
you know especially not the type of
deals I'm finding I'm James is quite
annoyed at me of this because something
that he only started doing recently
it's something that I've just stumbled
into and that's more the you know the
commercial reefer bond 7 bed 7 bedrooms
and more you can get so it's not the
bricks and mortar valuation on the
property it's more the commercial
valuation and I've completely stumbled
across it by accident
but it allows you to pull out all your
money it's such a good strategy and he's
kind of annoyed because it took him that
long to figure it out and two weeks in
I'm like dude I've got this deal he's
like yeah you can you can probably sell
that for quite a bit of money and the
investor will be very happy with it
because they can pull all the money out
yeah and that's what I've been focusing
on yeah because commercial value is easy
because they just value it based on the
rent exactly so as long as the lender
will be happy to say yes it is a
commercial property thank you
you're absolutely laughing exactly
exactly and that's when you get your
greatest returns and that's how you know
investors can pull all their money out
so I think we're the the mentorship side
of things especially James Armstrong
became so powerful is the fact that you
know there are a lot of deal sources out
there finding your four or five great
HMOs single led by refurbished refinance
all that but you know with James's
assistance I was almost able to skip
that level you can go straight into the
commercial side of things so talk to me
about the types of deals then you've
said commercial you said HMOs is that
what is it hmm yes okay and what sort of
areas you looking at the moment well the
first one I'm I'm not really so I'm not
really confined to one area this is
where I I find the deals wherever they
are like the first few I sold were in
the north of Wales the ones after that
are on the all the way on the East Coast
in Sunderland so you know I do a lot of
research I spend a lot of time on place
on online finding out which areas are
good finding out which properties and
then so I find an area that I think all
work and I just zone in on the area and
just my just go for it I spend a lot of
time there I build relationships with
with HTML managers and builders and
everyone so I'm building a power team in
every single area where I go so if
anything comes up they just give me a
shot you want I've got a deal for you or
potential deal would you like to take a
look at it when a couple of weeks we all
last week actually I saw this deal to my
investor and he wanted to view the
property so I'm like cool I'll meet you
there
and the HMI manager was there the
boulder was then everyone walked around
the property he asked all the questions
you needed to ask and he just loved it
so you know and that's really the kind
of surface that doesn't deal so so you
need to be offering you need to put your
investor first
and you need to get his questions
answered because if someone's handing
you six if someone if I'm handing
someone six round
I want to know exactly what it's for
yeah and and the last thing I want to do
is tarnish my reputation by just selling
a quick deal and running down the road
yeah because I think that'll probably be
the last deal you sell yeah and I think
as well I mean going back to when you
see so many people on Facebook trying to
flog a deal for 3 grand - right and it's
like you can't if it was me and I was
doing this from scratch and I was
starting out I would be happy to do my
first couple of deals with no fake yeah
just to be able to get a story about a
bubble reputation and it's like some of
these guys you know and there's the same
people that say to me you're charging so
much on your training we know why would
I pay 6 grand and it's like but for you
to try and charge 6 grand for a favor
then to bulk at me trainee it's like
it's just it was wrong with you exactly
he financially [ __ ] yeah I would
it's just some people I think that they
want to get they want they want to get
all the money themselves the one people
to set themselves irritate they want to
make woman himself the one people's take
them seriously but then they're not
actually they're not she taking themself
sumos I know I just having a little dab
or hoping it works crossing their
fingers listen this is a business yeah
you have to build your investors you're
gonna have to do you do diligence on the
areas you have to get trained it's a
this isn't a get-rich-quick thing no not
at all for you you have to go through
the pain yeah get you go through the
pain of going on the training getting
loans and through the pain of you in
rubbish houses the pain to finding an
area that was sucked yeah or maybe the
Aryan soap but it didn't work
yeah and now you making six grand for a
deal and you're doing a deal a week on
average Fair Play
could you you've had the wounds yeah
you've got to walk through the valley to
stand on the mountaintop exactly what do
you think yeah truly but then you know
you get to the top of the mountain and
you'll see you're actually really only
on a little peak the mountains even
higher yeah so yeah you get cuz I
remember I solved my first few deals I
was super excited you know I was really
you know you're buzzing because finally
it finally is a breakthrough you know it
took four months to get to the
breakthrough but it's there but I
remember I was sitting and I was sitting
at home one day I was sitting in my
office which is a nice corner sofa in
the in the lounge and I was sitting
there I'm thinking to myself oh crap I
need to find more deals now because and
it just reminded me of something that
John Maxwell said well it's similar
across the lines of the success money
people know that the biggest threat to
today's success is yesterday's success
and it's so easy for people yes I've
sold a few deals now and I think a
little bit of money coming in I'm just
gonna sit back and rest now but because
of my background in leadership I know
that okay now is the time to push
regardless you know the the freight
train is is started to move now we just
need to keep on adding coal to that fire
yes and then momentum is the key to
success and if you play it right play
your cards right then success will just
breed more success exactly well she'd be
a lot working with me then on the
Academy on the crash course it's been
amazing
I'm gonna be honest with you I'm not a
capper I'm not tend to keep to myself
especially in I'd call myself an
extroverted introvert so I like being
something but you know if when I go to
church and that I'm everyone knows me
was a big guy but then when I'm
in an unknown situation I pretty much
keep to myself until you know until I
get to know people so I'm not really a
cat Burma but you know forcing people to
go through that I think it really forces
you out of side of your comfort zone and
nothing grows within a comfort zone
yeah and the only my mission in life
especially for the last 10 years has
been to expand my comfort zone
yeah do we uncomfortable at the crash
course I was was and then I like the
training as well because if your uncle
if if you're having to do something that
makes you feel uncomfortable and
suddenly you know this is probably even
put people off coming to the crash
course go to the training but people
that want to come and sit at the back
and take notes and then think I'll apply
all this next week yeah that's what I
don't want I'm like no no so it's
getting people to do things like the
crash course I get people to phone
estate agents to to book viewing step
and and and people don't want to do that
I know just tell me what to do and I'll
go do it next week and I'm thinking no
you won't no you won't do it next week
let's see how I don't want potential I
want today exactly pick up the phone
yeah and people feel uncomfortable but
actually you've gotta get through that
yeah in order to get because you won't
as you said you're not going to grow
unless you're outside your comfort zone
exactly right top top piece of success
as we wrap up for someone watching this
and it's maybe a year behind you they're
saying I'm dabbling with a bit of this a
bit of that I want to be successfully
property but haven't got much money or
haven't got much well what's the key
thing they need to start doing I think
key thing is you know I think it's your
mindset first and foremost if you don't
believe you can do it
don't even bother yeah you know you need
to be committed to the process don't
think it's a rich get-rich-quick scheme
because it's not there's a lot of work
behind it you know I was very strategic
with the people I told about what I'm
doing I told the whole world I'm a
property investor obviously like your
training suggests but very few people
knew my journey yeah I was very
strategic about the people that knew
about my journey why is that because of
negative people out there you know I
surrounded myself with people who are on
the same journey as I am yeah or people
who supported me like one of my biggest
cheerleaders apart from my wife is my
you know my xbox
he's literally it called me constantly
like how's it going are you doing my
girlfriend's on the economy I did I did
um once again I'm not really on our so I
made good friends
yeah we're not a lot of friends but a
few good ones few good friends exactly
we made yeah a tight circle the support
you can share you on definitely that's
awesome yeah so come back to people who
are thinking about getting into I'm like
I would not recommend people do what I
did unless they 100 percent sure that
this is what they want you know the
decisions we might mean what do you mean
what you did so obviously to take out
the loans and things like that okay but
to put myself or to put ourselves in
such a position
yeah cuz you know we have a mortgage we
got bills to pay we got all those things
you know we and it's yeah it it was an
easy decision to make but it doesn't
mean that it was made the decision
lightly yeah you know a lot of forces
well you took our debt to go on my
training yeah but then you took action
yeah forcing the debt to be good debt
yes if you'd have not taken action and
treated it like an expensive
entertainment then it would have been
bad debt yes so when people say to me
Samuel would you advise me take out a
loan to go into training I'm like only
you come out that decision of course I
did that yeah when I was 17 I took out
loans to go on trainer mmm but I can't I
can't say for you know if someone says
should I take out a loan to buy property
depends on the property of course you
don't take out a loan to go on training
it depends on the person if you're going
to actually take action you did so it
became good debt yeah yeah Sampson and I
think people need to really that they
need to be sold on it themselves because
if you're not 100 percent committed to
this it's not gonna work yeah
flaky commitment even if I'm 99 percent
sure this is what you want
don't even bother this is really Wow for
us there was there was no other way you
know we got to the point where I
couldn't be earning any more than was
earning but you know there's so much
more than want to do in life we have a
big mission in life and you know where
we were we won't be we weren't where we
were wouldn't really facilitate what you
know what our goals are and what God has
put on our
to do yes what's got part in your heart
I just grow people you know I'm full
I've been in in leadership now for 10
years I've been developing leaders for
the last seven in the church yeah okay
so I've been developing leaders for the
last seven years I think we've developed
over 30 leaders and in but that is our
passion there that is our calling yeah
and we now just want to expand that into
and to you know not only in the in the
church out of things but also in the
business side of things because I can't
help but main to people that's just what
I do
so you know even though we are still
starting out in property there are
people that that want to start out that
you know the people that I shared the
stories with and we meet up regularly
and I share with him my story and I help
them further along their story but you
know I think John Maxwell in his book
the 21 irrefutable laws of leadership
talks about especially the lawn the
first law of leadership which is the law
of the lid that he says that your
leadership level is the lid on the
people around his potential yeah so I
cannot take people further than what
I've been myself yeah you know for
example your training as well you you
know you you can't take people further
than what you've been that is why you're
constantly pushing yourself to grow in
that area because you want everyone to
come that comes behind you you know to
be able to access what you've accessed
yeah and and that's really the most
important thing really just to and
that's been one of my biggest driving
forces as well because I know that I
don't want to be the the lid on anyone
else's potential so I push myself harder
than I push anyone else so basically you
becoming successful and becoming
financially what video by actually whoa
is actually gonna help those people that
you're training that you're working way
across but we're in the church your
missions I saw somebody well oh man I
can't wait to see you continue to
succeed I appreciate you coming out my
words thank you for the interview and I
look forward to catching up we will sue
senior winners Wednesday dinner
definitely
[Music]
[Music]
you